My name is Joshua Lessing and I'm
the director of research and development at Soft Robotics.
So I have a rather unconventional start in robotics.
I'm actually a chemist by training and I came into robotics when I
started my post-doctoral work with Professor George Whitesides at Harvard University.
And George Whitesides, he is one of the world's most famous chemists.
And he not only does work in chemistry,
he really just does work in anything that he finds interesting.
He's very very innovative.
And so when I was in his lab,
he was doing robotics.
He was doing composites,
molecular, electronics, water-protein interactions.
The origins of life even.
Anything that he finds interesting, he works on.
And he builds these cross-functional teams that
are designed to come up with new ways of thinking about age old problems.
So in the case of Soft Robotics,
he had people who were chemists like myself, chemical engineers,
people who understood bio-mechanics,
you name it, most of which were not conventional roboticists.
Try to think about what would be a new way of building a robot.
And where we got to was you know if you build robots
out of rubbers and plastics and other kind of squishy materials,
liquids, you get robots that
astoundingly have all these new properties that are very very interesting.
So that was some of the stuff that I worked on in his in his lab.
And when it came time to commercialize the technology,
I left to start that here with Soft Robotics.
I've spent my career trying to do bio-inspired research.
So, early in my career it was trying to develop
biomimetic catalysts so that
the oil and gas industry could turn methane into ways of making nylon.
Later on in my career it was trying to study
the fundamental molecular properties behind elastin,
which is the the rubber that makes up
the soft robots that are people and animals and it's a remarkable material.
So nature made the best rubber,
how do we replicate it?
And so moving here to the work at Soft Robotics,
you know, nature has made the best gripper ever conceived.
You know what can we learn about these biological systems and
how can we incorporate their design principles in the things that we make.
Just because, you know, they're remarkable.
There isn't an incredible amount of computation that goes into the use of your hand,
not the kinds of computation that that
most roboticists are accustomed to in the systems they built.
But yet, miraculously, you can do far more with
this than you could with a normal robotic gripper.
And part of that is embedded in the mechanical design, you know,
the muscles, and tendons, and the bones,
all the stuff that's in compression,
all the stuff that's in tension.
That whole mechanical structure,
a lot of the smarts are just built into how it innately
responds to the environment even without active controls of moving your muscles.
So what's exciting for me is having this possibility of delivering
this astonishing capability of getting ever closer to
this style of grasping through the technology that we work here to build everyday.